foreign
foreign foreign
what about you
alhamdulillah man you you're a little
bit tired people are going to say
something about me being tired people
always say something about you I don't
know what it is boys but uh you know
just so we don't have to make this
longer than it has to be bro because I
know you're tired you want to get some
sleep I say we just go right into it
and guys if you made it this for 150
viewers in the Stream mashallah smash
that like button right now let's get at
least 500 likes while we're still live
and show a lot of the algorithm and
let's jump right into it
they're all like having a Croc dropping
crosses and their album covers it on
screen they they use Satan to promote
their music it's anti-christian in the
west is a fun thing that people use it's
an aesthetic choice but I like the fact
that Islam doesn't tolerate any of that
and I I think that most Islamic people
have their heads screwed on properly
where they have a sense of guidance that
they can follow that keeps their
Morality In check I just grew up with
this stuff right like
I guess having a Russian Mom especially
the place where I'm from in Russia is
also
um you know my entire family is Muslim
my name is Imam it's Arabic
so you know that was just the way I was
raised from a young age so
yeah how Islamic are you
well not very
um yeah you're drinking stuff like that
I need a Haram button yeah drinking bro
coming here because in in Dubai you
don't really get good bacon
so you eat pork too yeah yeah
good but do you how often do you pray do
you go to the mosque I pray but I don't
go to mosque so I I pray every day yeah
and I believe in God it's just uh
there's a lot to follow I don't
prescribe her to religion yet okay
yeah I'm exactly yeah probably
I'll come to you yeah when you're ready
I'm guessing let me guess because uh
We've agreed were you an atheist for
like 19 years never [ __ ] never that's
the only thing but I've never never been
anything I was seven or eight years old
literally praying to God
you never had you never had like a edgy
atheist face never okay cool I was
called atheist even the school I used to
call atheist idiots yeah I'm like yeah
yeah I'm sure we came from the [ __ ]
big bang so what do you think about
Evolution no
no Evolution like I I don't know I just
I don't believe it bunch of garbage I uh
look there's things that I I know for a
fact and I'm just so well educated on
for example the Jib Jab right
um and this stuff like Evolution I just
haven't looked into that like for
example stuff like you know the weather
changing right like that I just know for
a fact that's a scam right uh recycling
is a scam too right it's also a scam yes
in Minecraft yeah in Minecraft so
yeah that's that but when it comes to
Evolution I haven't done much research
on it but yeah
I believe in God so I don't particularly
believe that we all came from a [ __ ]
big bang and then we evolved from
monkeys and or it's funny when you look
at like those like Nat Geo things and
it's like we we actually evolved from a
tadpole that became a a whale that then
became a bird that then became like yeah
all do you want to be when you have kids
I've been thinking about this one a lot
you know me man you look like you're
ready to go in
I just I don't know I found that funny
they said recycling's a scam
I just thought I don't know I thought
that's funny it's fun a lot but um
uh I don't really know what to say to be
honest uh his name is Iman mashallah
that's true his his family is Muslim the
whole thing about it'll come to you when
you're ready is okay that's good that's
good I don't think it's really bad but
at the same time it's like it's it's
right in your face it's right there
Islam is right there it's in your face
it's so clear
um I just wanna I just wanna talk to
them inshallah I just want you know to
discuss Islam I don't know what's
holding them back to be completely
honest
inversing together yeah
they were they were before us Nico went
to Romania
[Music]
bro
it's kind of weird if you're looking at
it it's almost as if
it's almost like they were cropped in
because sneakers like just like looking
straight off into the camera the entire
time
um did you see that comment bro
oh what'd it says that must be put in a
museum
why it was not it's not that special
role
Charizard looks like he needs a
Scooby-Doo
bro these comments have me rolling bro
I have the people here don't even know
why you call Charizard bro but if you
know you know isn't Scooby Snack that
thing that gives you like that power up
I don't even remember where the Scooby
Snack was I remember Scooby Doo is but
not a Scooby Snack
wasn't that like um
like a edible
I think so bro Loki yeah odd rights uh
are you guys from Canada no but we will
be soon I'll be with us Insha'Allah
um when is Iman featuring so I got in
touch with Iman and we decided that we
are going to be doing an in-person
episode
um either with him in Dubai next year or
he's going to come to Canada next year
um I did then kind of tell him okay but
what about like a stream can we do a
stream like sooner than that you know
and I just haven't heard back from him
inshallah when I know you guys will know
I think that would be pretty amazing
um just to kind of tap into you know a
lot of the things in his mind and why he
thinks the way he thinks
um particularly about things not just
related to business because you know
being a multi-millionaire
um you know him being a
multi-millionaire and only worrying
about investing and his agency and you
know crypto and a lot of these things
that he's doing
most people that do interview him they
do tap into a lot of these Avenues but
for me and I'm sure the other brothers
can agree on this that we would like to
talk about some non-money related things
too particularly about his journey with
Islam or just God and religion and kind
of bring them home if we can insha Allah
inshallah I think it would be good man I
really think it would be good because a
lot of the time these people their
atmosphere is so unislamic it's so
ungodly in general it's just so secular
it's so materialistic it's so
consumeristic so when they're around
these people you know that's all they
hear that's all they see so that's all
they care about I think inshallah it
might be refreshing to get on a podcast
with people who are going to talk about
God going to talk about I'm going to
talk about religion they're going to
talk about proper morals proper values
and things that really really matter and
just get away from this this you know
the stress of this this Dunya to be
completely honest
um I like that Iman was never an atheist
I think alhamdulillah I think that's
that's uh they're called sneak off guard
bro
yeah yeah because I think sneaker wants
to you know he wants to be able to
really relate him on that in that way
because he could relate to Tristan Tate
in the way that you know they were both
atheistic at one point and they both
came to the conclusion that it doesn't
make sense atheism is not logically
feasible there needs to be a God that
kind of brought everything into
existence in the way that exists today I
think that's a very logical thing to to
assert
I think that's beautiful they just need
the The Next Step they need the next
push that okay God created everything
that exists he created human beings with
this intellectual capacity he must have
sent some kind of guidance or message or
something to instruct us what our
purpose is on Earth
you know
I agree bro I agree
um I saw this comment bro from Jupiter
writing greetings from Poland no Muslims
in the 200 kilometer radius bro
mashallah
um and then I want I want one of y'all
to address this this comment someone
writes bro imagine being Muslim and
thinking that you still have to find the
truth
imagine being born Muslim yeah
yeah but I mean bro we were born Muslim
yeah I kind of still have to find the
truth or let Allah guide us later in
your life yeah yeah it's it is it is sad
in my opinion that you know at the same
time like what does born Muslim mean
born into a Muslim family you know that
doesn't necessarily mean you're born
upon Islam and practicing Islam we're
still also you know born into a secular
liberal Society we go to secular liberal
schools we learn secular liberal values
so how are we not born you know secular
liberals
and that's that's essentially what
happens
yeah bro we grew up here learning the
same things you guys are learning
being fed the same stuff in school that
you guys have been fed
um so at the end of the day you know
Allah can judge that you know
and I hope people know that's a that's
the whole point of secular liberalism
the secular part that's the whole point
of it they didn't make it some kind of
like atheistic liberal liberalism they
made it secular liberalism so you can
have your religion
right and a Christian and a Muslim and a
Jew and a Hindu and a Buddhist and all
these different beliefs can all come
together in one agreement which is that
no religion triumphs the other no you
know religious view can Triumph the
other we all unite upon this one
disbelieving ideology which is
liberalism that everyone should just do
whatever makes them feel good
that's the whole point of liberalism so
no matter who you are Muslim Christian
Jew whatever you all go to the same
schools learn the same stuff and you are
taught the same exact things and taught
to be the same exact way
um I agree I think the the commentary
agrees on that too alhamdulillah
2024 and I'm saying 30. [ __ ] that like
like if all things go to plan Maybe
38. 38 yeah oh you had a lot of time
yeah
oh good for you yeah uh can you ask uh
Iman what his idea of God is I want to
explain mine I want to see how much it
aligns with you my idea of God is very
broad I don't like the idea that God is
a man in the sky like that that this is
what I don't it never made any sense
that God would be a person like and
people are saying like oh you think God
is gender fluid no I don't even think
God is a is a person at all I think God
is like
this is something this sounds corny but
it's like I think God is like the ocean
or sometimes when the the breeze hits
the trees in a certain way or when you
feel love and you feel that connection
with somebody else there's God right
there God is everything good God is just
love is good it's a connection it's how
everybody
is has some sort of connection it's like
when birds all fly in the same direction
or when there's Karma that you know is
real when something happens to your
friend from across the country and you
feel it that's God is like an
all-knowing energy and it's hard to
describe God because it's so
look when you're do you pray yeah look
when you pray not enough When you pray
you experience what God is right and
it's it's something bigger than yourself
and you basically it's that feeling look
I feel as though you and I both have
pretty big egos When you pray
and when you're really tapped into yeah
your ego's gone because you realize that
you're dealing with something that's
it's greater than you greater than you
yeah right and it's all knowing energy
yeah so for me that's you know that's my
experience of God
I didn't think you had a big ego
I've heard someone say that when you did
the stream with Jordan so I saw I didn't
watch the stream but I saw some of the
comments
um
person in the sky
how does I don't know how that sits
right with anyone bro to be honest yeah
yeah actually there's a few points
actually bro I'm so tired I had to bring
my notebook out so I can make everything
because I've been forgetting everything
recently Bismillah
um the whole God is not a man in the sky
man that's beautiful
that's beautiful that you know his
future is intact he knows that stuff
subhanallah even Allah he says you know
in the Quran
that that phrase
there's nothing like unto him and um uh
basically all throughout Islam you see
that we cannot anthropomorphize Allah we
cannot assign you know uh human
attributes or animalistic attributes or
physical attributes to Allah and say he
is like a manner he is like this or that
or anything like that even like in
Judaism you know the first commandment
here is your Lord God is one yeah I
think the second one is he does not
resemble anything in the in the ocean
anything on Earth or anything in the sky
you know so imagine saying God is a man
in the sky you know what I mean like a
man who like a man that walks on Earth
but he's in the sky it's not a lot like
it's crazy and um the whole talk about
you know God is not you know he's not
non-binary in that stuff he's just he's
not even really I forget the word to use
but like you you can't assign any gender
to God at all because he's not like a
man bro Allah I love that he much and I
actually had a discussion with people on
Tick Tock that were trying to say Allah
is non-binary technically because he's
not man or a woman I'm like that
phraseology is so illogically incoherent
and the reason for that is because the
whole point of non-binary is that you
have the capacity to be male or female
but you are neither or you you are a
combination of both
not that you're not a biological being
at all so it's so incoherent that people
say these things so I'm glad that he
mentioned that because it shows his
fitras intact and the last thing I want
to say is the whole thing of you know
God is like the the you know the the
leaves flowing because the wind and all
that stuff and the ocean and all this
the nature that he's mentioning
you know when I first listened to I'm
like bro that sounds like some shirk
that sounds some like some messed up
stuff but if you think about it all he's
saying is that you know he's doing what
the Quran tells him to do they not see
how Allah raised the the sky the you
know the heavens do they not see how
Allah plays the mountains firm they not
see or think about how Allah created the
she camel you know how she was
constructed Allah tells us to look at
the world look at the creation
and that's exactly what sneako is doing
he looks at the world he sees the
creation and he's like how could this
come without something so great so Grand
if all this beautiful nature exists in
such a beautiful you know coherent and
and just civilized manner which we call
nature
how could it come from Something That Is
Random that's not possible I think that
is truly again beautiful masha'allah
what do you guys think brother Arnold
what about you
bro I don't have any input I mean that
was beautifully said bro alhamdulillah I
think so too did you have times when uh
before Islam pre-islam in the jahiliyah
that you could relate to that like your
idea of God was was not just like a man
in the sky like you thought it was
something more Divine than something so
yeah well I mean before with Muslim I
saw
Allah is like the origin that of which
you me and everything else stems from
that's what I explained it as whenever
when people would say like oh what is
God to you this is what I would explain
it
um and it's I mean that's kind of what
it is
that's kind of what Allah is if you
think about it that's fact we all stem
from Allah like Allah is the creator
what do you think about brother Abner
writing I swear Rami is so fine uh
brother brothers
he is pretty fun I mean I gotta withhold
myself and keep the Haram does to myself
sometimes
guys this is not a blessing
I'm I'm about to I'm about to play the
video bro before Anna gets out of pocket
yeah when you did the stream with Jordan
so I saw I didn't watch the stream but I
saw some of the comments people were
saying that yeah where did you get rid
of that how did you get rid of that
validation seeking I think a lot of guys
watching this are in that phase right
now I think uh yeah I think look there's
a lot of people out there and you know I
totally understand there's a lot of
people out there where they want to be
that guy but they're not that guy yet in
2019 even though I was making [ __ ]
millions of dollars a year and I was a
you know I made my first million dollars
profit you know because a lot of guys
talking Revenue as well I made my first
million dollars profit in a single year
at the age of 18. so crazy you know 2018
uh 2019 I was or 2018 I made my first
movie in 2019 I made 2 million or right
around almost 2 million so even though I
was making millions a year
I still didn't feel like that guy like I
might you know my reality was there but
my identity didn't match up to it so
yeah you know I think uh you know once
you're
Once you walk this path long enough you
realize okay this is just me right like
I don't need to
prove anything anymore like my
accomplishments speak for themselves so
what is your ego
I still have 10 20 of that when does it
come out I haven't noticed it yet I
don't know like uh when's the last
example you could real life example you
can give where you thought back like man
I probably shouldn't uh dude like I
think uh Chad it doesn't take dumps on
chicks I'm saying that's people in Dubai
he doesn't do that how do you know that
yeah what was the last time it's come
out and you've been like I should have
checked it I don't know maybe like
podcasts and stuff like that you know
podcasts sometimes I'll come on podcasts
and I still feel like maybe I'll got
someone to prove but also the thing is I
think sometimes I sound so bougie and I
think people think that I'm trying to
sound bougie but I don't know I think as
well it's like just I grew up in London
you know so I grew up around a lot of
money I just didn't [ __ ] you know me and
my mom didn't have any so I just think
like I don't know especially for an
American audience I might come across
pretty bougie and uh you know I get a a
trust fund a lot of times and uh it's so
funny I posted a screenshot when I was
first moving to Dubai when you open your
company that they need to know your mom
and your dad's name yeah and uh I
messaged my mom I was like what's my
dad's name and she was you didn't even
know I don't know my dad's name wow
right my biological father was alcoholic
abusive
well subhanallah
that was a tough note to end that video
off on man
um I love you know blessing I mean but
um bro the one thing that really stood
out was he said when he made when he was
making millions he still didn't feel
like that guy
like
my I was I don't know if he says it
later but does he feel like that guy
today you know with whatever I don't
know how much he's making but with
whatever he's making nowadays does he
feel like that guy yet or is he never
gonna feel like that guy because I feel
like a lot of people are chasing a dream
thinking that when I make this much
money I will feel like this
and a lot of the time is just not true
because
I was actually thinking about this I
made a video on it actually the whole
like
um social solidarity and that stuff I
won't say any trigger words here but
um thoughts feelings and actions work in
a triangle and I was talking about
thoughts in particular but this kind of
corresponds with feelings as well
people think thoughts are like a cloud
that you know they fly by in the air
and you know they don't affect anyone
they don't affect anything
but just like clouds move in the sky and
rain falls from the sky for very
specific reasons and by very specific
forces the thoughts that pop in your
head and the way you feel and the way
you feel about yourself
are also caused by very specific things
for very specific reasons and a lot of
the time has nothing to do with what's
outside what's out there you know going
out and earning money to feel like a
certain person a lot of the time it has
to do with who you are as a person so if
you change your beliefs about yourself
and you change
um
uh you know your your kind of philosophy
in life and you work towards achieving
whatever that philosophy is
then you will think feel and act in that
way and you will feel like that person
and one good clear quick example is like
the prophet Muhammad
we work to be like him right we know
islamically we worship Allah we obey
Allah we want to be good servants of
Allah we have the blueprint the prophet
peace be upon him he lived that life we
want to be like that firstly it starts
in Europe Nia your uh you know your
basically your intention to God and then
once you have your Akida your belief set
straight you just try and act like the
prophetam and the more you do things
because the prophet saws did it and
because they're good things to do the
closer you will feel to him right to
being that guy and by the way that guy
is the prophet peace and blessings
what about you
oh bro what about you
no I want to know bro because a lot of
the conversations me and you have been
having after you reverted to Islam is
how you know your ego and I don't I hope
this is not over sharing with the with
the YouTube audience but how your ego is
generally something that you have gotten
to come down after becoming a Muslim
and it reminds me of when Iman and
sneaker were talking about ego and when
you're in Salah you know where you're
praying to God because I don't know if
they're doing Salah I really don't I
can't just assume Iman is doing Salah
but praying however he says he is
your ego's gone have you have you had
any relation with that
um aside from Salah after becoming a
Muslim that you want to share
[Music]
I mean I I honestly I'd agree with what
Iman said
was like I still feel like the ego is
there
and like it's I don't think it's ever
gonna leave
you know like I just
I'll do my best man I I keep praying to
Allah I keep humbling myself submitting
myself
um
I am finding that there are some cheat
codes
in this game that we call
life the Dunya it's like
and Allah gives us the cheat codes you
know for the most part one of them he
says that it's you give salika right
like I'm sure if you guys notices maybe
like at some point you you give someone
something in charity it might be like a
smile or something like that and when
you give them that it's like bro like
that immediately impacts you boy like
softens your heart and makes you feel
just like
a little bit more like in that that
state of gratitude
you know and usually we're in the state
of gratitude when we're at our lowest
and then when we're the highest it's
like the state of gratitude is no longer
there and it's almost like a state of
arrogance begins to take over and then
it's only it's not long before we get
humbled like Allah humbles us he strips
something away to like bring us back
down so that we can see like ah look
I was straying I was you know falling
away from this so
um yeah bro just to like sum it all up
think we're all gonna have ego for the
rest of our lives it's just a matter of
keep bringing ourselves back
to that homo state
that's fair enough bro that's fair
enough I'm sure that Rami can can relate
to that because I definitely can relate
to that but once you come into Islam
it's almost like knowing that there's
someone not someone you know I don't
want them coming after me saying yo we
call the law of person bro
a day that is so all-powerful and
perfect that is so above us that when we
we submit ourselves to him to Allah that
act in and of itself not only is it
elevating Allah in our eyes and in our
ranks and our perception but it's
lowering ourselves and I think that it
makes us more grounded and level-headed
when we interact with other people too
we're always coming from a place of not
high and mighty anymore you know what I
mean so I do agree with you that the
ego's always there but I think after all
of us came back to Allah that it's
definitely been way more manageable and
Allah has been putting Baraka in our
lives to the point where it's not high
in Mighty anymore
yeah and just to add to that point about
submitting to Allah
like for example like
just to define wisdom wisdom is putting
something where it belongs right so like
two pieces of a puzzle together you're
not gonna put the wrong piece with the
wrong piece that's not wise right I'm
not going to put a like a hat on my foot
that's not where the heart goes that's
unwise Allah he created you for the
purpose of worshiping and submitting to
him
meaning that like two puzzle pieces that
fit properly you as a human being
worshiping Allah recognizing Allah
obeying him and submitting to him and
everything he says
is exactly the wisest thing to do and
will yield the best result you will feel
the best about yourself
we are not created to deal with
everything on our own and we all know
that that's why we have social systems
and societies
but not just physically and empirically
and out in life but internally and
spiritually
we are created
in a state of
basically loss like Allah says
and thank you for the correction it's
not it's not elephants it's it's
indeed mankind is in loss right
so if you worship Allah and submit to
him you will feel the best and that's
exactly what Allah says he says
all those who believe
and whose hearts are content with the
remembrance of Allah
indeed with the remembrance of Allah the
hearts found contentment if you want to
be content if you want to be happy if
you want to be chill submit to Allah and
you will you will be
with the video once it is done there's a
segment from our our Channel our stream
that we did with sneako guys if you
haven't made that uh or watch that
Link's in the description right now
check that out once we're done this
stream
um but there is a part that I wanted to
highlight from the stream we did with
Nico and see what you guys have to think
about that because it is something that
we commonly do here from a lot of DMS
that we get on Instagram
you mentioned this a lot on some streams
about Islam and then if there was one
religion that you identified the most
with would be Islam yeah I hear this in
a lot of stuff that Andrew Tate says and
a lot of people in the manosphere it's
always just talking good about what I
saw him if I had to bet on one religion
it would be a song
but then they don't really do anything
about it so my genuine question to you
is where are you friends of your views
on Islam and your own personal Journey
with God
I like the respect that Islam promotes
and I think in the west I agree with
Tate I agree that like you the the
comparison is that you could walk around
uh with the shirt that says Jesus is gay
and nobody will blink an eye like I've
heard I've had one-on-one calls with
people and they said like yeah I'm going
to a party that's that's twerking for
Jesus and I'm like what gee that's and
Jesus like people being anti-christian
is marketed as
it's fun it's something it's it's like
the rappers are all like having a Croc
dropping crosses and the and their album
covers it on screen they they use stay
in to promote their music it's
anti-christian in the west is a fun
thing that people use it's an aesthetic
choice but I like the fact that Islam
doesn't tolerate any of that and I I
think that most Islamic people have
their heads screwed on properly where
they have a sense of guidance that they
can follow that keeps their Morality In
check whereas a lot of other religions
and other
um
other
um thought what do you like trains of
thought it can it could derail you and I
think a lot of people now use their
political ideology as their religion
they use LGBT as their religion they use
like Democratic party and it's just like
that's not or they they adamantly
believe in
people and they worship celebrities and
politicians rather than God and I think
the best if you're going to follow
something it should be God
and in the west it hasn't been
Christianity and I personally grew up
Catholic
um just like on hell and Catholicism I
I've
okay so uh what are your thoughts so far
before I play the rest of the clip
um
I don't really have many thoughts I mean
I was there right so we had that
conversation with them
I think um
I think it's I think he's right about
the comparison between political
ideologies and religious ideologies
they're both just ideologies and they
Define who a person is and what they
think and what they believe and how they
act and all that stuff for sure
um which goes to show by the way if
you're raised secular liberal you will
be secular liberal at heart until you
you know kind of dig deep ideologically
and question your ideological beliefs
then you start from base one and and
objectively try and look at what is
the truth you know what is the most most
true or most accurate way to go and I
think he's starting to do that I
mentioned a few times I think the the
main contentions I think the main two
contentions you will have with Islam is
one proving God exists as an entity as a
being that sent religious scripture so
we can follow him that's one right
proving God exists and two proving Islam
is that religion in the religion that
should be followed which both are very
easy
they just need to be done
you know what I mean I think I think
inshallah where he's at
hmm
I agree bro
100
just seen a lot of hypocrisy in it where
like I we have something in in cabal
just for confession sit down and then
you you confess to the priests and you
say and then no matter what unit even if
you killed somebody like you can
literally confess a murder and be
letting it talk about [ __ ] out of
wedlock any sin and the priest will say
all right say ten Hail Mary's ten our
fathers and you're good and I sat in
confession it doesn't really sound like
they're listening I don't like the fact
that they walk around with the donation
basket
um I'm pretty sure it's the same with
with the mosque but
like the Christian Church doesn't pay
taxes a lot of people profit off of it
there's a lot of pastors like even on
YouTube some of the most highest um
Super Chat channels on YouTube are
Christian pastors and I've just seen the
way that they flock to it it just seems
false and
it seems like they worship a lot of
false idols and people use Christianity
for the wrong things but Islam seems the
most grounded and it seems like it
promotes family values and conservative
values and
more than more than most people that
I've I've spoken with and especially the
people that I admire the most
um since I was a kid have all found is
even people that did not grow up with
Islam found Islam people that I admire
like Dave Chappelle and Malcolm X and I
respect those people a lot and I I would
I like their trains of thought and I
think that that's a good thing to follow
that sounds good too
do you do you believe in one God
the truth is I want to more than I do I
think with my platform now and the way
things are going on in the west I think
it's important for me to promote
believing in God and I think it's a good
train of thought for people to follow us
but there's a lot of people that listen
to me and I think that believing in God
is the best is the best train of thought
to follow
but I had to be perfectly honest I want
to believe in it more than I actually do
Hmm this is something I really do want
to highlight bro because what do you do
with that bro what do you because don't
like I don't want anyone thinking that
he sneakers alone in this this is
something that a lot of people are
dealing with they want to believe in God
more than they actually do
um so Rami do you have any answer to
that
yeah I mean I think the best answer is
sneako habibi get on the podcast let's
come let's talk about God we will
demonstrate God exists and the way you
just think about it like this how can
you come to determine anything is true
or anything exists you would have to use
evidence and proof to demonstrate that
thing exist right for example that's
what they try and do with Evolution they
try and prove evolution is true they
look at certain they try and kind of
determine evolutionary patterns they
look at um
how you know genetics evolve and how one
species can evolve to another and they
have you know macro and micro on a small
scale with small uh genetic mutations
and then a big scale with many genetic
mutations over a long span of Time how
one species can become another species
and all of that stuff they have
evidences that they try and use to you
know push this forward same thing with
you know
um I with noise ignoring with um Albert
Einstein his theory
relativity and gravity and so on and so
forth he like revolutionized everything
he changed everything and he did it with
his his evidences his arguments and I
won't go into that too much so same
thing with God you don't know God exists
you want to believe him you're not sure
look at the evidence look at the
evidence there's two ways to come to
truth well three but two main ones one
is induction which is you look at the
evidences you look at the physical
tangible empirical reality like he's
been doing when he looks at the ocean
and the leaves with the wind and all
that stuff and he basically internally
feels the fitted off telling him this
has to come from God essentially it has
to come from a Creator and another one
and that's what science is essentially
induction and then you have deduction
where you deduce that for example we
know that you cannot have light without
a light source right there's light in
the room you can see me it's not Pitch
Black
you guys know that this light's coming
from a light source you know there's
lights in here correct or incorrect
exactly and you don't see my lights but
you see the result of the light
same thing with the ocean you know when
you look at the ocean the ocean has the
bottom of the ocean there's a floor
there's a bed of the ocean because if
there's no floor the water wouldn't be
there
right that's deduction the same way
you have things that depend upon other
things you cannot have an infinite
regression of things that depend upon
other things therefore there must be
something that does not depend upon
anything
and that's very simplistic and I know
he's going to say why can't that be the
universe and this is where I say get on
a call get on the live stream let's talk
about it I will demonstrate it to you
live in front of everyone why it can't
be the universe why the universe would
just be another contingent thing that
needs something to Define it and so on
and so forth but that's how you prove
God you look at the evidences it's
actually very very simple you just have
to go to the right places and learn the
right things
alhamdulillah
on her Army you guys free Tuesday at
noon
let me see
I'm asking you guys it's live bro
I'll bring the viewers on this
I don't know what about you should be
like 16 of your time
inshallah
then I will say this not a big
announcement or anything just for the
200 people that made it here we will be
live in Charlotte on Tuesday
um we're gonna put one in into this
situation and head on you know hijab
protests and all that
um or some other topic you know
nothing's fixed yet nothing's firm yet
um a lot of stuff that we can talk about
um
but I think that's honestly all we have
to say about this stream
unless one of your brothers has anything
else to say
on the alidaba stream or on this on this
uh thing with Nico and Iman gatzi aside
from you know like I had them both and
and you know just
make it clear to them because a lot of
times it is clear but some people just
they have a veil in front of them bro I
was just saying
yeah
um I think I've said enough man I talked
a lot
I Loki kind of want to react to a video
with you guys so I don't know if you
just want to do it now
in the Stream
okay what's the video though
it's uh it's this video that it's been
going viral it's a magician who says
that uh you can't do it on Muslims oh
yeah yeah I didn't watch it but I heard
about that okay let's go with them all
right I could keep talking while I'm
talking bro I'm just gonna download it
real quick I'll take some I'll take some
comments here
there was one person that said I mixed
two surahs of the Quran I wasn't I
wasn't like reciting verse by verse and
order I was talking about surul Asura
and I'll talk about the fact that
mankind is in loss and then on another
point I was talking about if you want
contentment then uh basically remember
Allah it will grant you contentment they
are from two different surahs for sure
but I wasn't like reading in uh in order
thank you
please bring back for us the hobby insha
Allah invite my job insha Allah also
people are talking about
certain things and if it's Haram and
Halal Guys don't give fatawa don't give
fat to us don't give rulings in the
comments please unless you you
definitely know
um what the ruling is especially if
there's a difference of opinion on the
matter don't just yell out one one thing
unless you're gonna include that this is
the majority opinion or something like
that on the top of you guys are asking
about there's a difference of opinion
um not so much on the totality of it but
in certain cases when it's allowed when
it's not allowed for example there's a
Hadith that mentions that basically
after 40 days that's when the soul is
put into the baby into the embryo
essentially so some Scholars say that
before the 40th date there's no soul
inside that baby
all right
um other Scholars say if the mother's at
risk then then it's okay to go through
with it and again there's difference of
opinion the best thing for you to do is
go ask your scholar inshallah go ask
yourself if you're curious about it go
ask your teachers and your Sheikh about
it
yes we will be held accountable for this
thing and the things we say may Allah
protect us I mean
person is drawn he
all right and it's locked and loaded let
me know when you guys are ready to start
all right there's one more thing I want
to talk about this I'm not going to go
into the whole discussion but what is
the punishment for not wearing hijab and
Isis and it is a scent to not write
hijab but there is no shitty there's no
shuttery punishment as far as I know as
far as I know again this is like
definitely the to delete someone that's
not the punishment bro yeah yeah this is
the fifth question to go get the ruling
go ask the I've never heard of any
punishment for not wearing hijab
especially because what is hijab hijab
just means covering men have a hijab too
just not the hydro scarf specifically
and there is no HUD capital punishment
for it at all so what's going on in that
part of the world with all that stuff is
completely Haram it is completely hot on
right I'm not saying it's Halal to burn
hijabs it's not I'm not saying it's
Halal to take off hijabs it's not Haram
it's a grave sin 100 but they're both
they're both basically idiots both sides
are stupid they need to come back to
Islam hmm
all right Bismillah
when the person is drawn he yes
definitely does the amount of alcohol
matter sure if a person is drunk he
sleeps he has no control over himself he
loses awareness so he's already
vulnerable basically alcohol lowers
vibrations instantly then it is easier
to work it is easier to attach an entity
and it is easier to take possession of a
person's mind
does it mean that it's more difficult to
influence a person if he keeps his
thoughts in Purity yes absolutely one
faced with various religions it is very
difficult to influence Muslims they are
in a constant connection with the
aggregor they do Namaz every day and
read prayers on a daily basis they are
constantly under some kind of a dome so
it is very difficult to influence them
when you start impacting a person he
begins to address in a prayer indeed
many of them are very different from
those who come to church only when
everything is bad in their life they
come to pray and then for five years
they forget about God some cannons and
so on Muslims as a rule passionately
believe and passionately give energy to
their aggregor and this aggregor
protects them very well
I got a question before we even continue
the rest of the video what is this
aggregor the other video is going to
answer to um
what she's referring to is God
let me let me let me search this up bro
I have no idea I mean you can take over
the floor
oh yeah so uh it's found a lot bro the
voiceover was killing me the whole time
but the message received nonetheless
that's exactly what we believe as
Muslims we believe that the Quran and
our Salah are are protective essentially
she described it as a dome but uh we
know it's a protection against the Jinn
and when she does what she does she's
working with the Gin she's working with
the Shelton She's she's trying to get
you to you know either do Haram or to
get the Jinn to enter you and basically
promote Haram with you within you and
when you look at certain things I don't
know if it's a Hadith but islamically we
know there are certain things that
increase the likelihood of being
possessed by Jinn one is when you are
obviously in a state of constant sin
then you're not remembering Allah but
more specifically when you're doing
things like you know zinna from
promiscuous things
um like I don't want to use the term but
you know
doing that one actions Haram a lot
um you're more vulnerable to it when
you're in that state when you're very
angry when you're very sad when you're
in a very emotionally volatile state
that makes it more easy does like with
the Ayah I mentioned before puts you in
a state of contentment a state of
um a state of taqwa when you're
remembering Allah constantly yeah so of
course it's going to be hard for them
correct brother John asks uh can someone
explain the Jinn
um so we we did a lot of videos bro we
got you know Abu Ibrahim whose name who
was uh definitely learned one when it
comes to that who's a friend of uh Tim
humble and we went into Jin sir
evil eye husted all that type of stuff
so you know you can you guys can watch
that if you want a little bit more info
on that but before we go on I got the
definition pulled up of agrigora
basically it's an occult concept
representing a non-physical entity that
arises from the collective thoughts of a
distinct group of people
historically the concept referred to
Angelic beings or Watchers and the
specific rituals and practices
associated with them
okay so basically she has no explanation
for what's going on so she's making
things up basically we're protected by
Allah she can't explain it so she's
using the term aggregor congratulations
like subhanallah
time I mean I see I see where they're
coming from bro because without
understanding one thing you're gonna
have a theory or model to depict it in
some other way
that's why it is very difficult to work
to make any kind of influence on a true
Muslim believer
is this some kind of a go to Gregor well
for them yes this aggregore is good for
adapts who contribute good energy to it
how do you sense it for instance you
have found an energy trace of such
person what's next do you try to drag
him somehow to visualize the Strat and
you fail or how do you do that it
disappears I cannot get a grip on it I
focus on it but something immediately
knocks me out of the flow just like that
or I visualize the person in front of me
clearly and can affect him even at a
mental level but some image is not
created in my mind at all I even look at
a photo reproduce an image but it
vanishes from my mind thus I can clearly
see that a person is covered with
something
does this only work with Muslims it does
for me
nowadays there are very few people among
Christians who truly believe even those
who write in their comments that God is
in the soul that they are all faithful
Believers but in reality they are not
even most often they write that all this
is a sin but then ask in a private
message how to make a robin spell such
cases also happen a robbing spell a
robin spell what is it it means pulling
a flock or some benefits Beauty money
success in other words pulling off
something good from another person there
is shift in when we dump some crap on
someone else and there is pulling when
we take something good from another
person could you please tell us if there
are people to whom you cannot connect or
influence them by various magic methods
in any way
there are such people if there is ritual
protection on a person it's not even
possible to connect through cards if
someone has put ritual protection over
him or if an entity is in a person's
service it is also difficult to do that
it happens that a person has a strong
ancestral protection he has a powerful
prosperous richkin from generation to
generation and even looking at the cards
you cannot read information from him he
is covered as impenetrable it happens
you touched up on an interesting point
that when a person experiences strong
emotion he opens up to the invisible
world
but what if a person he works in himself
controls himself and doesn't even love
any of the low qualities to manifest
does it mean that he belongs to a
category of people to whom it's
impossible to do anything by means of
magic rituals
nothing is impossible there are
difficulties there are points that
you've mentioned where it would be
difficult to work with such a person
it would take a lot of manipulation to
break his will
this is energy consuming and not every
practitioner will be breaking through
that door for so long someone will just
say hell with it he doesn't give in
there are such cases is it possible that
he will never give
I mean I mentioned emotion first and
then she mentioned uh emotion in in that
way
um subhanallah
I had a point and I forgot it what what
do you guys think
it's so weird it's crazy it is crazy
it's not surprising though is it
no of course not it's not surprising
he would come out and talk about it
that's what surprised now she would
actually come out and talk about it like
this I don't think they're allowed to do
that to be honest
um subhanallah but um
yeah at the end of the day
people are gonna you know not believe
this so we're not gonna use it to give
dabble with our religion and tell people
that oh look at this magician she can't
tell what someone's come to Islam
it's all like hype it's all unseen
anyways and none of that really is
important for the for the dawah the
reason we're watching it is for the
automation of Muslims to remind them
that this is something that's very real
she describes she literally described
right she described past it has said is
when you're so envious of someone not
only do you want what they have but you
don't want them to have it right um so
and she mentioned that that there's like
a a pulling type A type lawyer like you
take something away from someone and a
pushing type where you kind of throw
something on someone but why does this
matter it doesn't because Allah
says in the Quran that nothing will
strike a person except of Allah Wills
right that's what we know right I can't
think of the Ayah exactly but Allah
tells us that nothing will basically
befall a person unless Allah Wills so if
these people are plotting against you
and whatever if something happens only
because Allah allowed it to and it
certainly doesn't happen because Allah
did not allow it to at the end of the
day that's all that matters these these
people they're the Shale theme they're
gonna they're gonna end up in the
Hellfire
they're gonna end up in the Hellfire the
humans and the Jinn they're gonna cry
they're gonna burn they're gonna scream
because they know what they're doing she
knows what she's doing imagine being
this person who can't touch Muslims when
working with the Devil
and doesn't come to the conclusion oh
maybe they're on the truth maybe I
should hop over there on their side and
be on the good side yeah
I mean bro and and that's the thing bro
like I wanna
I wanna kind of agree with you uh on
what you were gonna say about
um that these things are are not just uh
the answer you know like when someone
looks at it and says oh you know what uh
a sorcerer or a magician can't influence
Muslims therefore you know give doubt
with this and I agree with that but
these things are Iman boosters and I'm
sure you you guys agree with that you
know when you look at a lot of these
books that were mentioned you know a lot
of occult books don't want to get too
into detail you know because this is a
live stream that's not edited can't
really bleep anything out but when you
look into a lot of these books and and
rituals and how to attract the Gin how
they these sahiros these magicians do
call upon the Jinn a lot of the things
that they do is desecrating the Quran
desecrating the name of Allah and really
doing immoral vile things bro including
things that are major sins
um such as the LG TV Electronics uh
movement you know and a lot of these
things that they do are very obvious to
be sentenced bro
um even people that have taken
psychedelics on again don't take this
when I sing take psychedelics you know
a lot of ways to connect to Allah we
made a whole video on that but people
that take cycle psychedelics and they
understand their energy very well you
know what a lot of them do
is they say that they understand their
self and their spirit and things that
damage their soul and then when they
come into Islam they're like oh you know
what all these things that were Haram
actually damaged my soul all these
things that are not Haram and and are
beneficial for us they they help me feel
better in my soul you know so again you
can take these things word for word as
we're instructed by Islam or you can go
out and and kind of learn the hard way
but we don't we don't recommend that
obviously you know
doesn't give in there are such cases is
it possible that he will never give in
did you have such cases in your practice
I had once there was a man who didn't
give in at all he felt a strong impact
but didn't give in were you personally
acquainted with him or did you get his
photo roughly speaking no how to say it
was an order but I met this person once
that man was an athlete very hard
tempered and he had self-control a
really tough one athletes and military
men may have such a temper his willpower
was at such a level that it was very
difficult to work with him even through
evil spirits in the end I refused
self-control at the level of emotions
right yes discipline self-control demand
controlled and distinguished his
thoughts from Alien once Jesus had no
effect on him he was fully aware such
people are very difficult to work with
there are such b people indeed what do
you mean by the word awareness when a
person understands that something is
wrong with him that he goes against his
principles let's say he will never cheat
on his wife he has the principle that if
there is one then it's forever I attach
an entity that pushes him you should
cheat you should sleep with that female
client and his principles definitely
take over that's what awareness is about
a person doesn't succumb to any
provocations that are imposed on him and
intended to break his will
but if someone is already attached to
him can this principles not be of his
own that's exactly where awareness comes
in you realize how come these principles
not be mine my whole life you mean who I
am I right right I lived my whole life
with this word of these thoughts come
from when a person begins to turn on
such a protective element he immediately
weakens the effect of an entity or a
haze a protective element is a search
for oneself isn't it yes it means to be
on you know it's like hypnosis when they
begin to put us into hypnosis but we
catch this moment and start reciting a
poem in our mind for example with us
immediately interrupt the state of
induced hypnosis the same is true when
working with magic when a person begins
to realize that something is wrong with
him delve into himself try to control
his emotions and follow his principles
it is very difficult to work with him
thank you
and that is it bro that is it
you'll notice the um
the interviewer like his face
like there was a part of him that like
was like is this really is this real and
then there's another part that's just
like basically swirling and stuff
along
someone wrote a language is she lying or
is she telling the truth about her
deception who knows
thank you
huh
may Allah keep us safe from this angle
that means
I mean yeah again you know Yani we don't
we don't need anything from her who
cares you know she's another person and
she ends up in the Hellfire like why do
we care what you should just say anyways
to stop doing what she's doing but you
know she sees how if this is true she
sees how protected Muslims are
and she's not going to make the logical
connection that you know maybe I should
go over there stop doing what I'm doing
um and I if what she's saying is true
she doesn't even understand it bro she
doesn't even understand it herself she
doesn't know about Jen why she's not
talking about Jen or she purposely
trying to leave things out or she's just
making things up we don't know who the
heck this lady is
um
honestly I don't think it matters you
know what this lady says and it
shouldn't really be much of an Iman
booster for anyone what should be an
Iman booster is just Allah telling us
about these things and the process that
I'm telling us to protect ourselves from
them and giving us the solution on how
to protect yourself from it so the
solution is Sharia
read what I've been told
the last three surahs of the Quran
um
three times each inshallah
I love you all for the sake of Allah may
Allah reward you for everything you do
you all inspire me more than you know
happy may Allah
hi boys I say we wrap the stream right
now not much else to say inshallah guys
make sure you tune in Sunday inshallah
day after tomorrow Sunday at 12 p.m
Eastern Standard Time That's 5 p.m 5 PM
UK time that would be the next time that
we go live Insha'Allah and Tuesday
Tuesday we're going live with alidal
Insha'Allah uh same time 12 p.m Eastern
Standard Time and keep your eyes up for
a debate next week
that's all I'm going to say leave it at
that
all right and with that being said